oh ouais ivre avant le coup d'envoi pas de disque
tu sais j'ai essayé de faire une publicité pour
mon nouveau film pendant le jeu mais
apparemment ce n'est pas familial ce que
je sais que tu crées un Family Guy
c'est ce que je leur ai dit mais qui est
dedans ça a Charlize  Theron oh ouais
Liam Neeson eh bien, j'entends qu'il a un énorme
ouais, nous avons tous entendu ça, alors ce qui n'est pas
familial, oh mec, sois fier
que tu veuilles voir la bande-annonce aller quel
copain
euh salut va voir la bande-annonce pour mon
pote  met le nouveau film à un million de façons
calme à qui tu parles je ne sais pas
oh hé regarde c'est la glace pourquoi est-elle si
grosse donc ne fond pas c'est en fait vraiment
intéressant comment ils le font c'est cette seule
entreprise à Boston qui est allée  sud si
vite
l'ouest américain est un endroit terrible dans le
temps tout ici qui n'est pas toi
veut te tuer des gens ivres en colère des
animaux affamés hors la loi le médecin qui
n'a pas pu la sauver elle avait un doc dissident
qu'est-ce que tu étais censé faire je
souhaite la bienvenue à un nouveau membre  dans
notre communauté bienvenue dans notre ville géniale
qu'est-ce qu'il y a avec cet ours chaque année les gens
meurent vraiment tout le monde reste immobile les gens sont
morts les fans sont morts à la foire quelqu'un
miss Hearne est parti aujourd'hui s'il vous plaît ne
nous tirez pas dessus la nuit du sexe vous avez battu ce
mec sans arme  bats toi tu vas être un vrai
héros c'est le tireur le plus vicieux
du territoire laisse moi t'apprendre à
tirer
hé en cours d'exécution mec tu ne
devrais vraiment pas le boire cheval
Aimie prépare toi je suis sur le point de tirer une pleine charge
de ton  Tan
tu n'en as jamais vu oh j'ai l'impression d'
avoir juste un morceau de gâteau ou quelque chose comme ça
ha ha ha ha ha ha Tina Astaire Mila
Kunis Milliken est mort George le regard
cha-cha-cha Joe ils ont touché un butin
Wow tu es incroyable je  j'adore vraiment que
la mode la plus séduisante aujourd'hui soit de
simuler une grosse maison si j'étais un noir
c'est le tour le plus méchant que vous pourriez
me jouer un million de façons de mourir en
Occident
peut-être que la frontière n'est pas si mauvaise après
tout hé c'est un  doux jeune couple puis-je
vous intéresser folk  s dans un carburant miracle